all right so dc fandom's been crushing
it this morning i know they dropped a
little trailer on the flash and black
adam i haven't talked about them because
i was like they're too short to make a
video about but i think they look great
also you know that's the burton
batmobile but admittedly i've been
waiting for the new trailer for the
batman because i heard there was gonna
be a new trailer for the batman and we
got it and it looks great it has this
dark gritty arkham city-esque tone to it
that we already saw from the previous
trailer we don't see much of paul danna
was the riddler which is perfect it's
great i don't want to see too much of
him as the riddler but i'm excited to
see him as the riddler i'm excited to
see this iteration as the riddler
because before we have the jim carrey
show which works for the 90s but
even in batman forever i was always like
i like the john glover riddler from
batman the animated series i was always
much closer to a riddler i wanted to see
in live action and it looks like we're
gonna get uh the scary terrifying
genius that he is it looks like they're
doing the thing where he gets captured
but the plan's already in motion and if
i'm throwing out theories because it's a
video about a trailer i imagine he's
giving them all the clues to solve
whatever's gonna go down and they don't
even know it because they're not as
smart as him looking forward to seeing
that also it looks like batman can take
straight up bullets now bulletproof
anything but a straight shot [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
i'm not wearing hockey pads loving his
batmobile muscle car too because it
looks more like in the dark night movies
it was like oh bruce wayne had the
backing of wayne enterprises without
wayne enterprises really knowing about
it lucious fox was like i got your back
here's some sweet r d tech that no one
really knows about this one it looks
like it's more pulled back like bruce
wayne's like all right alfred it's you
and me no one can know about this and we
don't really have a lot of tack to work
with so we just need a muscle car and
we're going to soup it up because i want
to cruise through the streets of gotham
going family we see more of zoey kravitz
as catwoman and i like what i see i mean
yeah
they played it smart they were like here
leggy catwoman shots that doesn't
convince the internet i don't know what
will but she looks good so does oswald
cobblepot dude penguin in this trailer
okay if i didn't know colin farrell was
cast as penguin i would have been like
that's penguin obviously but the thing
is it looks nothing like colin farrell i
was like
that is penguin right it is
it's impressive though like you can't
tell it's colin farrell the grinch looks
more like jim carrey then the penguin
looks like colin farrell solid robert de
niro impersonation oh i'll say that
i got you family
but this is a great trailer overall it
shows you the tone that they're going
for and the tone is great it being young
batman man he's going right into the
fire on this one it's like oh hey you're
batman great test your intellect in a
way that you never thought possible
before you get in that souped-up muscle
car batmobile and you find those riddler
trophies baby the trailer did exactly
what the trailer's supposed to do give
you the flavor of the world you get
enough of the characters enough to know
where it's going with batman taking on
the riddler
and it doesn't spoil anything else this
is one of those trailers i watched i was
like i don't feel like i know the whole
movie how amazing is that alright so the
new trailer for the batman that was
dropped during dc
fandom have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you